shark tank star kevin o'leary and former
shark kevin harrington are facing
allegations of fraud you know we've
built an iconic platform for
entrepreneurs the famous business
investors have been accused of scamming
and manipulating hopeful entrepreneurs
in a lawsuit filed by 20 people across
the country e.t has reached out to
harrington and o'leary for comment
according to court documents obtained by
e.t o'leary and harrington are being
accused of working together to defraud
people through the alleged use of quote
fictional executives false promises of
financial success and even illusions of
being on the show shark tank itself
the reason they call me mr wonderful is
i'm the only shark that tells the truth
specifically the two allegedly employed
a quote predatory fraud scheme to induce
inventors and entrepreneurs to hire one
of the two companies inventorex or ideas
on the entrepreneurs claim they were
promised that they would receive help
with crowdfunding to start their
businesses if they invested financial
resources into them
after the entrepreneurs paid inventor x
and ideas on they claimed they didn't
receive the help that was promised
they also say that these companies might
not even really exist and allege that
they could both be a front for scamming
upstart investors according to the docs
harrington is quote a partner and
primary executive of inventorex and
o'leary allegedly quote endorsed and
recommended the same two companies
the entrepreneurs who filed the suit
said that their losses could be in the
hundreds of thousands of dollars per
plaintiff and the lawsuit is asking for
harrington and o'leary to pay for
damages economic loss emotional distress
and legal fees
o'leary has been a part of shark tank
since 2009 i'll give you the 200 000 as
a loan
[Music]
a fail and i'll
only and i'll only take
eight percent equity while harrington
appeared regularly in the first two
seasons of the show
you're here to do a deal today i'm ready
to do a deal et spoke with o'leary in
2018 where he opened up about keeping it
real on shark tank and what impresses
him in a hopeful contestant
when people walk in this door with their
hope and their dream
it can be intimidating but do you turn
it up a little do you turn the heat up i
don't like it when they're crying and
all that stuff come on you know this is
business it's tough you can't make it
through here what's the real world going
to do to you you've got to perform here
very well you've got to leave here with
an investment and we want you to know
your numbers but you've got to show us
that you know what you're doing and then
the real world will kick the you know
what out of you afterwards
[Music]
you